the cost of star citizen's campaign load
has been announced and it seems that the
studio didn't shy away from spending
some of that sweet crowdfunding money on
a list actors Cloud Imperium games
announced a large chunk of the cost
during citizen comment this weekend
names that may be familiar to you
include Mark Hamill Rhys Davies Gillian
Anderson and Gary Oldman who played the
character named Admiral bishops Oldman
is the only actor whose in-game
character has been revealed and he's
recently lent his voice to the role of
Lord war tech in lego dimensions as well
as Victor Rezanov in call of duty black
ops star citizen's campaign mode
entitled squadron 42 will also feature
appearances by Andy Serkis Ben
Mendelsohn and must strong you can check
out the full list of confirmed actors
and a behind the scenes video in our
story on site as the star citizen almost
91 million dollars has been raised for
the game so far by a crowdfunding and
we're still holding out for news on
April a stage let me know down in that
comment section what you think of the
cast inclusions and for everything star
citizen be sure to stay tuned against
but